So Katie, this is going to be a unit on unsupervised learning.
>> Unsupervised learning is something that's very important,
because most of the time, the data that you get in the real world doesn't have
little flags attached that tell you the correct answer.
So what are you to do as a machine learner in that case?
You turn to unsupervised techniques to still figure something out
about that data.
>> Okay, let's talk about them.
Given a dataset without labels over all the data points are of the same class.
There are sometimes still things you can do to extract useful information.
Like this dataset over here, where I would say this dataset is structured in
a way that is useful to recognize for a machine learning algorithm.
>> When we look at this by eye, it looks like there's clumps or
clusters in the data.
And if we could identify those clumps or clusters, we could maybe say something
about a new, unknown data point and what its neighbors might be like.
>> Or here's a second example of data.
Maybe the data looks just like this.
There's something we can say here as well.
>> Right.
So all the data in this example looks like it lives on some kind of line or
some complicated shape that you seem to be drawing in there right now.
>> Yeah. And it's, it's, it's used to be a two-dimensional space, with x and
y over here.
But some of it we can reduce it to a one-dimensional line.
So that's called what?
>> That's called dimensionality reduction, usually.
>> Dimensionality reduction.
So we learned about, a little bit about clustering.
>> Clustering is what we'll learn in this lesson.
>> And you can see here an example of something also called unsupervised
learning of dimensionality reduction.
>> Which we will get in a future lesson.
>> So these kind of things where you find structure in the data without labels,
they're called unsupervised learning.
And we're now gong to dive into the wonderful,
wonderful magical land of unsupervised learning.
>> Sounds great, let's dive in.